foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman is here
what it is we've got the rest of our
team here in the studio as well and
coming up today on this free public
minimal episode we're joined by Sleep
expert Jack delachio and we're talking
to him about
sleep problems oh we got so much to talk
about we also have an outstanding
lightning round question listener tip an
added value segment for you you can
check out the full two hour maximal
edition of episode 360 where we answer
four times the questions and we dive
deep into several simple living segments
like a massive or trash it obsolete
objects and a minimalist home tour that
private podcast episode is out right now
at patreon.com the mentalists your
support keeps our podcast 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck yeah they do Alabama
where would you like to start today
let's start with a question from Kristen
in Nashville Tennessee hi this is
Kristen from Nashville how can couples
navigate Sleep issues together without
distancing themselves from one another
or offending one another for example
I've had a long-term relationship before
with someone who snored so intensely I
spent many nights sleeping in another
room even when I'd have preferred not to
I too use a sound machine to sleep
because White Noise helps me get a
better night's sleep what are your
dating and relationship sleep best
practices
Jack I want to throw this to you in a
moment because my wife and I we have
different sleep patterns and she
struggled with sleep a lot more than I
do I I'm typically a sleeping Savant
except last night I got a titch of food
poisoning so I was up most of the night
and so maybe that's my first pro tip is
don't get food poisoning
I don't know that helps you out very
much though uh Kristen what I will say
is it's fascinating that sometimes it
does make sense to sleep in a separate
room if you have a partner who is loud
or rolling around or if last night if I
was rolling around in disturbing my wife
she's going to get a poor night's sleep
because it's constantly being disrupted
I use something called an aura ring to
track my sleep there are it's not a
sponsor at all obviously you know we you
could use an Apple Watch or a Fitbit or
any of these other products that track
your sleep and I find that to be useful
because it tells me about where I need
to improve and perhaps what I can do
better over a long period of time
however looking at one day's worth of
data like if I just look at my data from
last night that'd be a bit of a problem
that's that's kind of you you've not hit
the nail right on the head it's not
about your day-to-day results
um and when we're working with athletes
and all that we really try to have them
look at at very at the very at least
only a week's worth of sleep at a look
at it in one week increments and not not
daily increments because you're first of
all there's
um so many different products out there
different uh readers and they're not
they could be off by 50 one given day
just because of environments sounds
movements everything that may be uh
distracting it but if you're looking at
your results over a week over a month uh
then making improvements on it that that
makes a real difference that's when
those devices become useful yeah you
know it's funny when I was a kid I
remember watching like different TV
shows and they were sleeping in separate
beds and I didn't I didn't realize it
was because like they didn't you know
they were censoring like Mary couples
sleeping in the same bed but I always
thought that was weird but then I
actually started to notice it with like
relatives and like different people
where I'm like oh wow like that's
they've been married for so long and
they sleep apart and for for me that's
strange but like it's funny because
Mariah and I know we don't sleep apart
but we have this like the adjustable bed
and she hates it being adjusted and I
love it being adjusted so we have two
twin mattresses pushed together
[Music]
so essentially sleep on summer beds and
I'm just wondering in like 10 years are
we going to be in different rooms no
probably not um I had the snoring
problem too but I've done a lot of
things to kind of correct that but uh
yeah do you get any advice for for
couples like how do they sleep well
together well first of all that oddly
enough it's a growing thing people are
sleeping separately separate rooms
separate beds reminds me back to The
Flintstones yeah and and I was a little
shocked to hear that just a couple of
years ago but
um some some people that I I know very
well and well-known people out there are
you know have their two beds where
they're apart and their third bed where
they're together
growing thing yeah uh but ultimately I I
don't think that that's the norm I don't
think that's where people want to take
their relationships either
um and it is things to to deal with and
everyone's got to focus on their space
one of the big Solutions is what you're
describing that two independent beds
actually do make substantial difference
yeah if they're married together they're
they're they're it does seem like one
bed so you you are able to roll over to
one side to the other so you're getting
the benefits but also because you could
you can adapt to some of the Sleep
challenges that every individual has so
the one person who's slower snoring can
slightly increase the the angle of their
of their back and that will take away
some of the pressure in their in their
chest and reduce some of the snoring so
there are tactics that you can use to
reduce the snoring uh but everything
comes down to trying to align yourselves
but my issue at home I have a personal
issue at home is that my wife will go to
bed three hours before me so she's
ending her sleep cycle three hours
before me so when I'm kind of still want
to get going you know sometimes she'll
just turn on a TV or or turn on a radio
or you know but just like I bother her
when I'm typing for the first three
hours of cheese though
yeah but ultimately I I do think from
from a few people that I've coached I've
had this issue they've got to be a
little considerate and really look at
how this can blend together and be aware
of that sleep environment from the
sounds to the lights and and and and be
conscious because it's not just the
snoring it could be a TV set could be
lights could be a computer that's that's
on gotta you know eliminate all of these
surrounding distractions and stimulants
yeah absolutely I'm going to uh give you
five things that I have done with my
wife because she also she actually goes
to bed after me I get tend to get up way
before her so one thing that we've done
and this is not on my list of five
things is we sleep apart half the time
so we have a little guest house back
house and I was I'm so grateful I got to
sleep in there last night because I
didn't keep her up all night as I was
dealing with the issues that I had but I
tend to be a champion sleeper and I
wasn't always that way and my wife is
very similar she was very light sleeper
and everything Disturbed her and so I
would encourage folks to save this
episode and go back because I'm going to
recommend some things that are
mechanical things that are simple tweaks
that you can fix here are five of them
and then later in the private podcast I
have 12 more things to talk about with
with you jack so the first thing that I
did that really helped my sleep is I
sleep on a grounding mat in fact you're
sitting on a grounding mat right now so
is Ryan so is TK but sleeping on a
grounding mat the ones we have are from
earthing.com not a sponsor it's just
that we've had Clint Ober on the podcast
before but grounding really helped
regulate my sleep it improved my wife's
deep sleep it gave her more deep sleep
it actually gave me more Rim sleep and
so I balanced out to sleep when Danny
started sleeping on one we have Danny
unknown here he uh he and his fiancee
they immediately started having more
vivid dreams they noticed they were
grounding and it really helped them out
the second thing I did is lots of
sunlight especially first thing in the
morning I don't just sit there and in my
and hide under the fluorescent lights or
the LED lights I go out and I see the
sun on my skin and through my eyes and
on my face and I notice that resets my
circadian rhythm in a way three other
things I sleep with a sleep mask the
particular brand I use called a sleep
master I recommend this to everyone will
put a link to the one that I use in the
show notes it's the one that Ryan uses
it's the one that Professor Sean uses
and several other people that I know my
wife uses this as well a sweet mask it
really really helps with uh especially
when you're traveling as well but it
helps at home every night right before I
go to bed I put the sleep mask on it's
beautiful last thing is a nice pillow
for me now of course a mattress and
we're going to be talking about
mattresses later but everyone is a
little bit different here my wife and I
have radically different pillows I have
one from a company called bedgear.com
and she tried it out and hated it I
couldn't sleep cramps in her neck my
wife seems to like to take a pillow case
and put about three Chipotle napkins and
in it that's about the thickness of
pillow she wants that's about how mine
is too so we just washed our pillows
recently and I got the lumpiest pillow
so I I need to buy a new pillow actually
but that's the thing the pillow that
works well for me doesn't work well for
my wife it may not work well for you
Etc and I think those those five things
if you change those five things first
that's the the low hanging fruit I have
a dozen other things I want to talk
about but Jack what do you think well
first of all I want to say I'm really
happy that you dove into that because
I'm not aware how aware you guys were
gonna dive into sleep right so I'm
completely impressed with that and I
love it because we really get into deep
deep analysis on on what makes people
sleep and part of it involves the rea
the impacts of uh electric smog uh 3G 4G
5G and that's something that when you're
generally talking to a general consumer
or general public they're not getting it
really yeah uh but you're talking about
grounding mats and we
see we we we're in a position where we
work with institutional customers and we
work with athletes and we work with our
our consumer followers who want
something different who are open-minded
but because we have that such a wide
variety when we come up with a product
everything needs to be evidence-based
and so we've been analyzing blood work
and understanding how cell activities
your cellular blood cell activities
changes based on your electrical devices
your phones your computers during active
downloads during active phone calls it's
actually disrupting your body and these
are all parts of how
um your body's not a proper rest
um so we we we work with Quantum energy
and really looking on how we stop those
uh situations from happening so today we
we actually have
um a mineral formula that we've put into
our our uh our products as well which
eliminate any of those impacts from
happening so equivalent to um what would
have been a grounding mat however a
little bit more up to date because it
also impacts
um all the data signals that are
everywhere EMF et cetera exactly yeah
well here's what I'll say to Kristen
every choice you make cuts off other
possibilities so yes it is true that if
you're choosing to sleep in the bed with
someone who's disturbing you you'll
probably be disturbed now you can help
them like I help my wife be less
Disturbed she sleeps very soundly now
she is also a champion sleeper if still
a bit of a light sleeper but she has
improved dramatically now I am a big
time cuddler at night so uh yeah he is
Ryan knows this because we've been on
tour together and he would wake up and
I'm just holding on to him we're in
separate beds and somehow
I just want to cuddle Ryan no I know man
I know I know it stems from childhood
yeah the only thing I'll throw in here
is uh with Mariah and I because like we
have different uh sleep schedules too
but like we have an agreed like last
night we were like okay let's get in bed
at this time we're gonna read this book
and then we sit we read a book we get
sleepy we go to sleep together that
doesn't happen every single night but I
know that when that happens uh her and I
both get better sleep for sure but do
you and Michelle you guys go to bed at
the same time
I'm making a conscious effort to do more
of that yeah it used to be the case that
I would stay up a little bit later but
um I'm just I just don't want to do the
night owl thing anymore yeah it just
doesn't feel it doesn't work yeah I'll
tell you in my 20s you said 20 years ago
you started getting into sleep 20 years
ago I thought that I could like
asleep three hours a night and get used
to it yeah and I was specifically like
only getting three or four hours of
sleep like I'm gonna train my body to go
out for three or four hours of sleep so
I've been trying to catch up on my sleep
over the last 20 years that I missed out
on but when we sleep together like we we
we we we we do life together more more
effectively amen yeah um one thing I'll
say is that we all hear hear people say
communication is the lifeblood of
relationships but sometimes we regard
certain things to be too mundane to be
topics for communication and I think
it's easy for sleep to become one of
those things and I would encourage you
to talk about your problems and your
priorities as as it pertains to sleep so
if you're a cuddler like Josh and that's
a need it's important to spell that out
right and it's important to say hey
here's what I'm not willing to live
without or here's what I absolutely have
to have here are my expectations here's
where you're irritating me when we sleep
at night you'd be amazed at how many of
those things just go unsaid and when you
talk about it put it all on the table
then the two of you can get a plan to
get other to work on your sleep and make
time to do it together or make time to
get what you need when you can't do it
together I'm gonna get you a cuddle
pillow oh gosh I already do that I can't
stop me from cuddling Jack do you want
to wrap up Kristen's question here
before we move on I I think there's uh
also needs to be an effort of using your
bed for primarily sleep what I mean by
that is not work not read not not not
have life and in fact one of the things
is when you wake up in the morning don't
hang out in bed get out of bed if you
want to do something crawl up on the
floor and open your laptop but
the the brain the body has this this
memory and it's it it it it's easily
trained that's why it's impacted by its
surrounding by its habits the circadia
ribbon rhythm is is uh is is is
something that's memorized by the body
as well and if the more activities
you're doing in in bed when it comes to
again uh uh TV work any any type of
brain stimulation
um your body will your brain will be
active when it goes to bed rather than
preparing itself for the onset of sleep
the bed is meant for two things sleeping
yes and sex so get the damn TV out of
the bedroom amen Ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
the lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions your comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now Jack
throwing the lightning round this is
where we and our guests do our best to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response but not
really Professor Sean puts a minute on
the clock for you so you can ramble on a
bit uh we have a question today from bar
by the way we put the text to these we
call the minimal maxims you put we put
them in the show notes so you can copy
and share our pithy answers on social
media if you'd like and you can find all
of our minimal maximums in one place now
minimalmaxims.com Alabama what's Barb's
question how much deep
are we really surprised
nightly so here's my my pithy answer for
you you can put a minute on the clock
for me Professor Sean one man's enough
is too much for the next man now what do
I mean by that we all have individual
needs I've noticed this with my wife
we'll often go to bed at the same time
and I will get through my sleep cycles
and I will wake up an hour two hours
before her but I'll still end up with
more deep sleep or more Rim sleep than
her and so figuring out what is enough
is individual it's perspectile well I
did that in less than a minute let's put
them in on the clock for Ryan Nicodemus
oh my pithy answer is this living well
will help you sleep well and I think we
covered this exercise not drinking
caffeine past a certain time cutting out
alcohol not eating before bed I mean all
of these things are going to help you
get better deep sleep I mean to sit here
for me to to measure my deep sleep every
single night is going to stress me out
rather I would just like have some good
uh habits in my life that will by
default help me get better deep sleep
now I don't know how true this is but I
read this article about how deep sleep
there's a specific doctor who is talking
about how deep sleep can be connected
directly with Alzheimer's have you heard
this at all I have yes okay is there any
truth to that I haven't done any of that
type of research or studying on it but
that's that's aware of the research I've
got a close friend that's very involved
in that and uh they're following it
really closely yeah yeah it's nothing
that's proven yet but um there there are
some like loose loose links or even not
so loose links tied to Alzheimer's so
yeah deep sleep is definitely important
I will say this with your last six
seconds it's also tied to schizophrenia
uh less having less deep sleep and so
it's something worth oh I'm out of time
let's put a minute on the clock for TK
Coleman
all right here's my pithy I said it I
said it right for the first time in
history
the only thing you're supposed to do is
discover what works for you and then
dive in whenever you're struggling
between a few different viable options I
would say create a low-cost experiment
where for a predetermined amount of time
and a predetermined cost you can explore
it to see how you feel afterwards you
can do almost anything for 30 days I
tend to like 30 day experiments in
personal development or a 30-day
personal development projects where I
say I'm going to try this thing for 30
days and then afterwards I'm going to
take a look at my results and ask myself
do I want more of this or do I want less
of this so many growth strategies Health
practices and personal development
techniques are similar to clothes you
know if a shoe fits by trying it on you
know if a shirt fits by trying it on and
it's not until you try it on that you
can actually tailor it to your unique
situation
that's beautiful right under a minute
too look at that so Jack Let's uh let's
take us home here with Barb she really
wants to know about deep sleep and and
how much is enough how much is too
little what do you have to say to her so
um to in all the cases that we work with
we're looking at
everyone's got a certain amount of deep
sleep in the REM sleep that they're
getting with all their bad habits and
all the negative routines
um so the point for us is how do we
improve it because everyone improving it
that's what I was telling you earlier
about some of the players we're getting
minimum 20 Improvement well that's going
to be the game changer that's going to
be the life changer so if you're getting
you know uh only 20
in deep sleep cycles and we get that to
24 25 that's actually life-changing and
so that's where you're right on where
this is individual for everyone some
people will manage to clock in two hours
some people imagine it to clock in three
hours but the difference is if we're
taking you to two hours to two hours and
15 minutes it's a game changer for you
three hours three hours and 20 minutes
so that that's really there's no one
number that matches for everyone but the
goal is how how do you create this
environment and how do you eliminate
these stimulants to bring up that number
because you know REM sleep will have
direct link to mental recovery deep
sleep will have direct links to your
physical recovery you'll you'll get off
that injury list a lot sooner we were
doing a lot of work with um uh with
players and and and trainers even
looking at concussions ultimately sleep
and deep these deep sleep cycles are the
foundation to all of your Wellness yeah
you're healing everything else well
that's pithy too yeah right there deep
sleep is is yeah relation to your
overall Wellness that's great here's
what I'll say to wrap this up is I
noticed when I first got with my wife
her and she started tracking her sleep
she was getting around nine minutes a
night of Deep Sleep almost no deep sleep
wow and now she's getting over an hour
sometimes two hours a night because of
those dozen things that we talked about
earlier on the private podcast tweaking
each one of those gave five percent here
seven percent there eight percent there
and all of a sudden she's getting
multiple hours a night of Deep Sleep
totally changed her life it's like she
she's a totally different person ladies
and Gentlemen let's thank Jack for being
here today thanks so much for being here
man this is a great exercise
we'll put a link to his company Essentia
in the show notes malibam we got so much
more to talk about some other segments
now you and I are going to argue a bit
about light bulbs I'll be the referee
we're going to do a home tour as well
what else you got for us in the meantime
here's a minimalist Insight from one of
our listeners hi this is Marissa from
South Bend Indiana I recently had a
packing party for my iPhone I removed
all my apps from the home screen which
is different than deleting them this
means they will just be on the last page
and you have to search for it by name to
bring it up then for two weeks when I
needed an app I would add it back to my
home screen after the two weeks were
done I deleted all the apps I didn't use
anymore all right y'all before we get to
our added value segment this week big
thanks to Jack delacio from Essentia
we'll put a link to Essentia in the show
notes you can check out their non-toxic
mattresses and see if that is something
that appeals to you we also dive deep
into a whole bunch of sleep tips from
him on the private podcast real quick
for right here right now here is one
thing going on in the life of the
minimalist we've completed two Sunday
symposiums so far and we're getting
ready to go into our third Sunday
Symposium it's in Los Angeles only 200
people really nice intimate setting we
have musical guests we have special
surprises noon on a Sunday you can find
it at
sundaysymposium.com Ryan tell me about
your Sunday Symposium experience so far
it was awesome man really enjoying it
looking forward to doing more TK how
about you man what I love the most is
just the people coming together and
seeing how much laughter there is in the
room how much connection there is in the
room and I'm just looking forward to
continue to build on that me too what I
really like here is we're building this
community there are free tickets
available there's pay for tickets as
well if you want to help support us in
paying the staff and the venue obviously
it's not free to throw an event like
this we wanted to make it accessible to
everyone but only to 200 people to keep
it intimate keep it small keep it
meaningful and we're trying to find
different ways to interact with the
audience when we're there you can find
all the details over at Sunday
symposium.com for our added value this
week Bex and I have been downloading
this show called Severance have you
heard of it Ryan have you seen it I have
not but I've heard awesome things this
is on uh apple right yes okay yeah
you're like the 10th person to tell me
that it's it's on Mariah's list for I
put it off forever we don't watch a
whole lot of shows now that we don't
have a TV or Internet at home so I have
to go to a coffee shop and like download
an episode to your computer yes and as
I'm doing that you have to be really
selective right but then we watch the
first episode of this and it was like oh
the minimalist set design absolutely
stunning it it explores this stew of
seemingly separate philosophical
quandries and I think that's why TK will
really enjoy it so like what is
consciousness what does it mean to be
human are there benefits to escapism how
can work be meaningful to one person and
completely meaningless that same work
can be meaningless to the next person
right and it's really a show about
work-life balance your your brain gets
severed and so your work self is now
different from your at-home self this
sounds a lot like Westworld and maybe in
many ways it's like a minimalist version
of Westworld really yeah and although
it's completely different in its premise
and what I'll say is all of these
philosophical quandries that don't seem
tied together at all somehow they Loop
it all together but it's really about
the self and if I'm a different version
at work than I am at home is it two
separate selves or which one is me and
so ultimately it's about this concept of
work-life balance and you know if you're
a long time listener to the minimalist
we think there's no such thing as
work-life balance no one asks about like
driving life balance or eating life
balance it's just it's just one area
which we say work is this and then
enjoying life is something else and it
really comes out in the show in really
strange ways what made you watch this
it looked beautiful in the trailer like
it was beautifully shot the lighting the
atmospherics it seemed really harsh
minimalistic but then the depths of the
story is what made me keep watching yeah
it's always good to get a good
recommendation but there's something
special about discovering something
really cool like that that no one told
you about by the way Ryan we got a bunch
more surprise questions on the private
podcast this week like what are some
non-toxic mattress options for sensitive
people what things positively and
negatively affect your circadian rhythm
how does artificial light harm our sleep
plus a million more questions for Jack
and the mentalists and if you want to
hear all that from Alabama tell them
what to do check out the minimalist
private podcast visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
all of our archives recordings of Live
Events weekly home tours and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers like you you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com the
minimalists if you have a question or
listener tip for our podcast give us a
call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast
theminimalist.com follow the minimalist
on Tick Tock Instagram Facebook and
Twitter at the minimalists and to get
our podcast show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list at
theminimalist.com thank you Alabama that
is our show for today on behalf of Ryan
Nicodemus TK Coleman Alabama podcast
Sean Jordan no more Professor Sean
social justice Danny unknown
post-production Peter Emma The Immigrant
and the rest of our team there's so many
of you no wonder I'm losing sleep at
night
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn if you
leave here today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
is the opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
peace
every little thing you think that you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]